what is my top five battleships or
capital ships in sci-fi welcome to
sidetrack your sci-fi tv movie channel
[Music]
so i just did a video about my favorite
fighters in sci-fi and i had to follow
it up with my favorite big ships so
these are going to be the big boys i'm
going to get straight in there with my
top five and i'd love you at the end to
leave a comment and tell me what your
top five ships would be where am i right
where am i wrong in at number five is
the bc 304 from stargate
the dailist when it was built is just
one of those designs that isn't the
prettiest thing in the world it's
actually kind of ugly but it is a design
that kind of makes sense and fits what
it's supposed to be it's not supposed to
be streamlined and sexy like say an
asgard ship it was 200 meters to 225
meters long depending on the variant it
had lots of engines at the back it was
capable of ftl and traveling in
hyperspace it was very well armed with
16 vertical launch missile systems
they've had some nuclear weapons where
macro tipped it had up to four asgard
beam weapons and 32 rail guns it was an
incredibly well-armed machine and also
don't forget that it's a carrier being
able to launch anything up to 16 f-302s
compared to a lot of other ships in the
stargate universe it wasn't a
particularly powerful vessel until the
asgard shields and then the asgard
particle beam weapons were fitted
but the main reason why i love this
vessel is it just looks the part it fits
what it's supposed to be perfectly it's
not supposed to be pretty it's not
supposed to be sexy it's supposed to
look like something that we could build
today and
for what it's supposed to do
fit for purpose it's a beautiful design
and easily makes my top five favorite
capital ships in all of sci-fi
in at number four is the corvette class
from the expanse
now again this is one of those vessels
that just looks perfect for what it's
supposed to be
built by the martians it's a tank in
space it's very well armed with a keel
mounted railgun in later series also six
point defense weapons and two torpedo
launchers it's really is incredibly
maneuverable and again it's one of those
things it's a realistic design and say
what you like about the expanse one of
the things you have to say is that it's
a realistic very well thought through tv
series and that shows in the designs of
the ships
in this case it's exactly how i imagine
a medium-sized warship might look in the
future it's a brilliant design and just
one of those ships that you know it
looks functional but it also kind of
looks pretty
if you do like the content by the way
guys please consider hitting the
subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you liking
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also
consider becoming a fully fledged
sidetracker hit the join button all
these little things they really helped
me to keep the channel going in and then
those few little pennies that basically
means the wife will let me keep doing it
number three on my list is
the ownership that's actually kind of
like on the dark side
if you actually break the design of the
imperial star destroyer down into its
parts it shouldn't be a good looking
ship it shouldn't look right got lots of
flat edges and a massive triangle it's a
really big vessel nothing compared to
some of the other ships obviously that
we see but it really is the workhorse of
the empire if you want to project power
you need to be able to move large
numbers of steel around you know you
need to be able to move attacks thai
fighters men and this is what this
vessel is designed to do it really is
the aircraft carrier for the empire
so not only does it look stunning
it is a impressively powerful vessel
even capable of entering an atmosphere
you know in some of the later movies
when you actually see this thing
floating in mid-air using this anti-grav
drive
floating over city you can imagine the
fear it would genuinely instill in
people and how the empire kept all those
billions of people in line
through fear
this vessel even beats out the
millennium falcon which is obviously an
iconic design but
the star destroy for me is just
that little bit more impressive and
terrifying the uss celico makes number
two on my list
the conestoga class from the alien
franchise
the reason why i love this vessel was
because one aliens when i was a kid was
one of my favorite sci-fi movies
and this ship was just
really imposing it was designed to look
like a gun in space and my god did it
work
we don't know much about how this vessel
would work we don't know how it even
operated it seems to be like a massive
drone it doesn't seem to actually be a
crew aboard it
but
it's just a phenomenal looking design
and actually it was sketched out by
james cameron to look similar to the
pulse rifles from the rest of the film
it's an unusual design but it fits what
they wanted absolutely perfectly it's
supposed to look like a threatening ship
and
christ did that work
385 meters long the united states
colonial marine force used this as their
taxi in space but also it was incredibly
well armed it was designed to be a
gunship and
you know if you want to design to look
like what it's supposed to do
this vessel and this design completely
fits that you take one look at it and
you know exactly what this ship is for
there's no oh maybe they're here for
peace there it's definitely a shoot to
kill kind of thing
so
easily number two on my list of favorite
capital vessels from all of scifi
in at number one will probably again not
be a surprise to most people
it's the enterprise obviously
but the enterprise a the refit from the
movies not the original
it's one of those designs that's not
practical the neck is a stupid design
and by the way i'm not including the
designs from the jj abrams movies
because they were just stupid and just
ridiculous flappy things out in the
first one and then in this third one the
neck was just ridiculous just stupid
but the ones from the original motion
pictures were william shatner the
enterprise a is the vessel i'm on about
a refit of the constitution class it was
launched in 2286
and then refitting 2293 it had 21 or 24
or more decks
and armed with phases and photon
torpedoes
the reason why i love the vessel even
though it's not particularly practical
it's just a lovely design again it looks
like it's doing warp 6 when it sat still
it is obviously an iconic shape in all
of sci-fi and similar to really the star
destroyer in its components it shouldn't
be a gorgeous ship but it just is
it just works
and that's why it's number one on my
list of
all-time favorite iconic capital ships
in sci-fi
so get in the comments guys tell me
exactly what you think what would be
your top five
and tell me you know where i've got it
right and where i've got it wrong
if you are new to the channel please
like and subscribe and hit the bell
notification you could also consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
hit the join button if you enjoy the
content as always please stay safe and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you